the United States will be moving troops
into eastern Syria to help defend the
region's oil fields from Islamic state
now that's according to US defense
officials the announcement comes after
the decision by President Trump earlier
this month to pull American troops out
of Syria that move paved the way for
turkeys assault on Kurdish forces who
had been in close
American ally a ceasefire deal brokered
by the US has allowed turkey to
establish a so-called safe zone along
its border with Syria which it is now
patrolling along with Russian troops
well here's how Mideast analyst Marcus
Bickle described the situation in the
region in an interview with me earlier
they are there to protect the oil fields
from being attacked by the Islamic state
again together with the Kurds so you
have a Kurdish American small alliance
still on the ground but the major trend
is America is not only leaving Syria but
is giving up the Middle East as the
whole region to Russia as the new major
power in the region so is Russia's
influence in Syria set to increase yet
further and how should the international
community respond to Russia's
partnership there with a NATO member
Turkey those are just some of the
questions being discussed by NATO
ministers during a second day of talks
in Brussels Moscow is the new puppet
master in Syria Russia's defense
minister talks with the head of a
Kurdish militia there and it's clear
who's giving the orders that's the
reality facing NATO defence ministers
they're scrambling to catch up with the
political reality of post-war Syria and
more to the point the West's role there
there are different views and allies as
stated in the meeting also views which
are publicly known it was a strong
support for a political solution and a
strong a support for the stronger
international engagement German Defense
Minister Anna gret cramp karin bauer
proposed an international force to
police a secure zone
but she only had a few details for a
moment it looked like US defense
secretary Marcos per might support her
idea
I think it's finite because it's
something that we've been calling on our
European partners to do for quite some
time is to step up and do more so on why
I would be supportive of that
supportive politically we don't intend
on contributing ground forces or
anything to that operation the Europeans
had questions about the details and the
timing we're not against an
international security zone in principle
but the situation on the ground has
changed now that Turkey and Russia have
reached an agreement in the past the
Germans have often been slow to suggest
involvement in such matters but the
foreign minister said she had proposed
it to the Turks thus as he said often
that they showed themselves as very open
in our bilateral talks this could take
place with the involvement of the
international community and Turkey would
be open to talks about that offer hiatus
but when talking to the larger group of
ministers she'd only offered a couple of
sentences on her idea sources said she
said that was enough endorphin the
discussion process has been kicked off
it'll be a long process and a difficult
one but the first steps were very
encouraging Germany's defense minister
is still looking for support in Brussels
but NATO allies turkey in the US are
pulling in different directions well are
the two pulling hard enough to crack
NATO more than that we're joined by Ben
two Shella the heads of the MIDI section
of the Heinrich böll foundation it's a
think-tank close to the German Green
Party good morning thanks so much for
coming in we have high-level talks going
on in Brussels today at NATO is NATO
facing a threat to its future future not
from external enemies but from alliance
members well indeed I think Nature has
never faced a more difficult challenge
now with a tomato or not the two major
but one major partner of NATO
one major member being so much at odds
with the other I don't think we've ever
witnessed a situation like that before
okay it's hard to find to find a
disagreement like this between
Turkey and the United States but it
could be that they're actually working
together that they have agreed with
Russia to create this safe zone for the
resettlement of hundreds of thousands of
Syrians possibly so it's just that if
you look ahead what should that alliance
then this deal what should it consist
and make his in the end they are not
looking into the same direction they
have different interests and whatever
deal you should that be that includes
all of these interests okay the you the
German government is indicated it wants
to see some type of international troop
presence do you think that has any
chance at all I don't see this coming
because the situation is very
complicated as you mentioned we have
NATO partners looking into different
directions and Germany is not really
willing to do anything out of NATO and
also it would not be patentable to do
anything outside that framework so this
idea that has been floated will be very
difficult to implement also it was not
really spelled out how should that work
in cooperation with Russia and Turkey
was what the German defence minister
said but these are exactly the parties
that are bombarding northern Syria one
in the West one in the East so how can
you cooperate with these two violating
international law
okay now the United States President
Donald Trump said that American troops
would be pulling out of Syria now it
appears they'll be redeploying to the
Conoco gas plant that's near daya's or
and they'll be teaming up with Kurdish
forces there what do you make of that
well that's the most bizarre maneuver
because as you learned over the past
days Kurdish politicians have come
closer to the regime in Damascus and
then the cooperation with Kurdish troops
that are at the same time affiliated
with Damascus that is not something that
will work it doesn't have a perspective
to really work out because both are not
on the same page regarding the future of
Syria and regarding what is possible to
protect so this move to remain in their
reserve which is not anywhere close to a
border how are the u.s. going to protect
their troops and who do they need to
copy to be able to do that okay those
are some good questions in America we'll
be looking at Russia and Turkey have
created this resettlement zone there
in a safety zone but it's in effect a
resettlement zone for Syrian refugees
now living in Turkey while NATO and the
West have been looking on inactive we
have the the NATO meeting today looking
at this who knows what they'll come up
with something on it but the
resettlement that's being planned by
Turkey is a massive violation of
international law and human rights
conventions that Turkey has signed off -
indeed it is and it comes at the price
of ethnic cleansing also the North you
have seen a hundred and eighty thousand
people fleeing already from the Kurdish
areas further to the east these people
will not be able to return and
especially not a resettlement is taking
place by turkey forcing Arab Syrian
refugees out of Turkey into that zone so
we see different levels of violations of
international humanitarian law and that
of course is inacceptable
do you see NATO becoming a spectator to
this ethnic cleansing as you describe it
NATO has been a spectator to the whole
conflict in Syria it is not the first
time that major human rights violations
take place so at the moment it has
maneuvered itself in a very difficult
position how to intervene at this stage
of the conflict benta sheller from the
Heinrich böll foundation thanks so very
much for coming in thank you